en parlant de gamme de jantes ont scellé
le figurez vous que ces défis on se sont
sortis des frontières de touche pas à
mon poste et même des frontières de ces
huit surtout avec jean mathia regardez
bien le magnéto c'est incroyable ce qu'a
réussi à faire ou placés à guillaume
genton agents laetitia c'est incroyable
mais je peux vous dire s'il attendait
vous n'avez pas vu vous avez pas vu si
vous regardez ça fait dix ans vous
laisser sur toi selon métro plus que ça
me concerne je pense à beaucoup n'y voit
aucun talent vestimentaire autant pour
faire placer les mollahs c'est un
champion voilà
[Musique]
alors on cherche
les éléments blasphématoires sur
ou la garder
vous vous considérez effectivement que
vous avez à y gagner une sorte de moule
agnostique ulaga politiques voulaient
effectivement aller dans le sens du vent
sur ses news
pour parler comme les jeunes je crois
que beaucoup de français en depuis un an
à attendre de faire la malle à c'est à
dire de faire ça mais aussi en action
mais vous son action c'est la zone
tu joues tu sors c'est ce que vous
dénoncez jour il faut peu théâtre si
j'osais je sens minorité si les zones
merci
[Musique]
tout le monde est réparé il ya aussi
l'économie c'est la drogue sait ce que
c'est ce que c'est c'est quelque chose
qui était résumée par un rappeur
tellement de biff générés par le four
là où je suis effaré c'est que jamais
s'y affrontent au rabais
les seniors
je suis libre et des trucs
pauvre aujourd'hui oui parce qu'en fait
j'ai
ce parti est devenu mon joli costume
comportant pétanque jeux pokémon du bois
[Applaudissements]